i
[Música]
me gusta mucho el teatro
siempre me gustó
cuando tenía seis años me acuerdo que me
lleva a mi primera clase de sorpresa
porque yo no le había pedido la
comunidad musical como verona melliza no
gemela porque eso tengo más belleza
obvio
qué bueno ella después de un tiempo sí
comenzó a hacer comedia musical pero
volviendo libre una clase más allá de la
sorpresa fue realmente increíble
fue cuando me di cuenta de que era mi
pasión
de todas formas en mi colegio primario
una tan común hacer artes sino deportes
como fútbol o rugby y hockey hummer a
las chicas pero yo no me dejé llevar por
eso
yo soy ha dispuesto a hacer lo que
realmente me interesaba y apasionaba
incluso me acuerdo del teatro me permite
desarrollar mucho más guía social
me acuerdo de infancia siempre me
preguntaba se interesaba por ver si me
gustar una chica de la clase
la presentaba
hasta que consiga mi primera novia
agustina
pero bueno la realidad es que el teatro
lauro mi infancia siempre sentí que abrí
montón de puertas cerradas adentro mío
flashforward siete años después al
comienzo de mi secundario en el colegio
nacional de buenos aires dejó el teatro
para dedicarle un poco más de tiempo al
estudio
y me voy dando cuenta de la variedad de
actividades talleres y deportes que en
el colegio tango navegación cerámica
natación esgrima judo etcétera
fui observando qué
algunos de mis compañeros les gustaba el
tap
otros cantar otros el fútbol que algunas
de mis compañeras el básquet otras la
danza otras el fútbol también
y también que algunos de mis compañeros
no le gustan mis compañeras
o que había compañeras que gustaban de
otras compañeras
me di cuenta de que había amigos míos
que
siempre me gustó las chicas y ahora no
como mi amigo jean que tiene novio
o que siempre les haya gustado mirar
fútbol y capaz yo no lo hacía
o que siempre habían querido hacer algo
de chicos pero nunca se dio
yo les creía no podía hacer
no les había gustado siempre mirar
fútbol no era como a mí que siempre me
gusta actuar
o sea sino cómo te va a empezar a gustar
algo dejar de gustar algo de un día para
el otro si siempre se te presentó con
una opción era como miami a juli que me
dijo que siempre tuvo van a hacer fútbol
pero al final no se dio
si te gusta lo haces y punto ya está yo
de chico quería actuar y me llevaron un
taller de teatro
yo de chico quería actuar
soy chicos se actúa antes y sobre teatro
ya venía actuando
actúa con decía qué
no bajó al fútbol
cuando decía que me gustaban las chicas
y que estaba busca conseguir una nueva
novia
o cuando me ponía contento de que mi
hermana hiciese comedia musical
porque no me ponía contento
no me ponía feliz porque
mezclaron esta primera clase de sorpresa
porque eso no quería hacer teatro yo
quería ser copiado musical y no me a
juli quería ser fútbol y mi amigo jean
quería tener novio no novia
entonces qué pasó
bueno el factor x
estamos guiando
millón por ejemplo está en todos lados
no estaba realmente redactado
está en los hogares
en las publicidades en los juguetes en
la historia
están sus cabezas y también está en mi
cabeza
y nos dice que tenemos dos posibles
personajes
una es fuerte
macho varonil bruto heterosexual obvio
y viste con pantalón corbata y tiene el
pelo corto
y el otro bueno la otra es coqueta
delicada y sensible heterosexual también
obvio y tiene vestido usa tacos y tiene
pelo largo
y eso es lo que hay
el azul o el rosa
los chicos o las chicas
mate amargo o mate dulce
e
[Música]
el fútbol o el hockey
el teatro o la comedia musical
y estoy diciendo el teatro o la comida
musical no
para mí nunca existió la otra opción
para mí siempre fue teatro y punto
a mí me eligieron
a todos nos eligieron
nadie pudo elegir
quien dice que nos tenemos que encerrar
en un personaje
si al fin y al cabo el personaje que nos
dan es un conjunto de escenografía
disfraz y maquillaje
entonces qué pasa si sacamos para
escenografía de atrás qué pasa si nos
maquillamos la cara si no sacamos los
disfraces que tenemos puestos tiramos el
guión a la basura y dejamos obedecer a
ese director que nos comanda órdenes
qué nos queda
a propia monos de nuestro personaje y
construyamos lo que construyamos lo como
queramos
yo trato de recordar a la pequeña y lo
que un día yo a solas de teatro y dijo
esto no es comida musical
este es de preguntarme qué pasó y
recomiendo que todos lo hagamos
porque la única forma de no convertirnos
en director es en la obra de otro
la única forma
es revelándonos contra que nos dirija
[Aplausos]
[Música]